any pet owner knows the dogs can quickly
become an important part of the family
we like to take them along for the ride
whenever we can it's probably okay to
leave them in the car right let's ask
some people and see what they think all
the puppies say it's like a 75 degree
day okay how long do you think you can
leave your dog in the car 20 minutes two
minutes just run in buy some toothpaste
and get out maybe 5 minutes 10 minutes
would even be a long time ideally I
would not leave a dog in a car but I
think 10 minutes with the windows down
15 minutes tops
I don't know like an hour so what
happens when there's a long line or you
get distracted inside the store
in order to understand this better I
decided to sit in my car to see what it
really feels like okay so I'm going to
sit in here for 10 minutes I don't have
any windows cracked but according to the
AVMA cracking the windows actually makes
very little difference listen the car is
a perfect storm for pets what we worry
about is they're not used to a really
hot car it's humid in there because
they're panting there's no ventilation
and a lot of times there's no water this
is dangerous for pets and dangerous in
general according to the thermometer it
just hit 90 degrees in here if you're
getting hot you stay calm that's not how
dogs think they don't think I'm getting
warm I'm getting hot let me be calm no
they get more anxious I'm going to take
off my jacket
cuz it's freaking hot you're starting to
sweat they do sweat a little bit between
their paws a little bit on the top of
their nose but that's it and so dogs
mainly cool themselves through something
called evaporative cooling
that means they pant the harder you pant
the more worked up you're getting and
now you're getting even hotter this is
terrible you get a dog who's panting
who's overheated kidneys cosecha shut
down we can see direct heat damage to
the brain multi organ failure is the
take-home message here I'm starting to
get like lethargic and sleepy and sweaty
and really really uncomfortable and
that's why a lot of dogs if you see them
they're getting hot you'll notice them
getting more dull they'll seem listless
lethargic just not themselves I'm good
this is getting so gross and so sweaty
and this is terrible I will say this
never leave a dog in a hot car never
leave the windows up
always keep your dog out in an area
that's fully ventilated all done 10
minutes and the car is over 95 degrees
right now
that sucks that's terrible
the breeze feels so good I'm so happy to
be out of that car if you do have a pet
who you think is having heatstroke there
are some keys to prevent preventing the
worst from happening get your dog to a
vet wrap them in cool towels blast the
AC and never submerge them that sucks
that sucks it gets really hot and it
sucks even worse for pets because they
don't know what's happening they're just
they're miserable and confused I'd
rather have a vet say to you
everything's fine just having a little
bit of heat stress which is a mild form
of heatstroke then to say you waited too
late so when in doubt go to the vet
so what can you do if you see a dog in
danger the Humane Society suggests
taking down the license plate model and
make of the car and having local
businesses try to locate the pet owner
but if that doesn't work you can call
the local non-emergency police line or
animal control and wait for them by the
car what do you have to say about great
just chewing the microphone perfect